welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Jedi Exile Ezra Bridger has a
complicated relationship with his
lightsaber as we see on the Ahsoka
series turning down his fellow Rebel
Sabine Wren when she offers him back his
old lightsaber that she has been
struggling to wield do you think what
thing do you lightsaber take it you keep
it I don't need it besides you've been
training very funny no I'm serious take
it I gave it to you it's yours now at
least take a blaster no
the force is my Ally that's all I need
thanks to e favormart for sponsoring
this video we'll tell you more about
them later from here Ezra goes on to do
some Force empowered hand combat and
while it's not clear if he's always
making physical contact with his
combatants who needs physical contact
when he got the force that's what I tell
myself when my ex didn't want to cuddle
I Honestly Love Ezra's cheer at M way
style Force combat in this episode
especially the way he repels Shin saber
in that moment it's like force squeezing
it but is Ezra pulling a Last Jedi Luke
and tossing aside his longtime blade or
from the collection of grand Admiral
thrawn will Ezra acquire a new
lightsaber the blade of the one member
of the ghost crew few have expected to
return in this series that's right will
the Ahsoka finale unveil pretty Prince
Junior as a live-action Cameo of Kane
and Jairus I know it seems kind of out
of left field but there actually are a
lot of questions left on the table about
Kanan and Ezra and lothal the loath
wolves and now Kanan and Hera's son
Jason that I think can all come together
in this final episode of Ahsoka in this
episode I'm gonna break it all down for
you so in the Ahsoka series Sabine Rand
has repeatedly struggled to wield Ezra's
lightsaber eating against Shin on
sea toss in episode 4. and as we saw
with Shin fighting Ezra and Ahsoka in
episode 7 as we're completely unarmed
for that Shin is kind of a lightweight
which doesn't look great for Sabine
seems like all that talking huyang
has been doing about her is grounded in
reality but sabine's Journey with Ezra's
blade mirrors her training with a
darksaber in Rebels season 3 which Ezra
actually alludes to this episode makes
sense of course she trained a little
before back when I was first learning I
remember that episode of rebels is one
of the most important ones to watch as
it details the history of the darksaber
and the Mandalorian people but there is
a critical lesson from Kanan Jairus it's
heavier than I thought energy constantly
flows through the crystal you're not
fighting with a simple blade as much as
you are directing a current of power
your thoughts your actions they become
energy they flow through the crystal as
well and become a part of the blade and
Sabine never truly forged that
connection with the darksaber and that's
why she handed it off to Boca tan Crees
but the question in on this Ahsoka
Series has been will it be different
this time with Sabine and Ezra's
lightsaber in the rebels final episode
when Ezra makes his big sacrifice play
to break away from the rebels and sneak
aboard throwing the Chimera he
shares his glance with Sabine and it's a
bean who directs everyone's attention
elsewhere Ezra leaves his lightsaber
with chopper so that he can face thrawn
unarmed that's part of Ezra's plan and
then Chopper later tosses Ezra's
lightsaber to Sabine in the fight and
this is how Sabine is left with it it's
just kind of fascinating though that we
are now seeing the Chimera return in
live action in these final episodes of
Ahsoka because while we've only seen
parts of the ship like the hangar for
the typewriters and the laat Le gun
ships filled with night Trippers and now
apparently storage for what I guess are
night sister caskets this ship actually
contains all kinds of Star Wars goodies
it was on this same ship where thrawn
stored pieces of the lothal Jedi Temple
that Palpatine's Hollow projection used
to try to tempt Ezra with the vision of
his parents who had died as were
resisted in the final episode of rebels
but thrawn is the collector of all kinds
of arts and Antiquities also has in his
private quarters a Jedi Temple guard
mask on its desk as well as the freaking
Holy Grail from Indiana Jones the Last
Crusade Clone Commander gries helmet
from Revenge of the Sith grie was one of
the guys Yoda beheaded on kishyk during
Order 66 there's a bust of an abedneto
that's ello asti's species that was
created for the force awakens there's a
digital version of Ralph mcquarie's
concept art that Rebels uses a painting
of lothal and then the iselamiri which
are lizard-like creatures from Timothy
zahn's aired the Empire novels which
were immune to the force and amid these
anti-force Bubbles as they are in this
artwork and now perhaps the most
valuable position among that collection
might be Kanan jairus's lightsaber if
you're throwing a party and you want it
to look like you hired a professional
planner e-favormart can help you do just
that e-favormart is a One-Stop party
supply shop that can bring a
picture-perfect party to life at
wholesale prices they have everything
you need to throw an impressive event
perfectly tailored to whatever theme you
want they have balloons a table and
ensure but they also have huge statement
pieces like floral arches Buckle
machines and champagne stands there are
over 10 000 products to from an order
ship within 24 hours we're throwing a
huge Ahsoka finale party on the break
room so to really blow it out we ordered
a ton of balloons LED lights and enough
Greenery to turn the set into a Gala
from a galaxy far far away if you want
to take your parties to the next level
and support our Network click the link
in the description and use the code the
break room for 15 off your first order
the last we saw that lightsaber was in
the rebels season 4 episode Doom when
this is right after kanan's death when
Governor price presents kanan's
recovered lightsaber as proof of his
death as for General cindola I have
something better it's true then but the
Jedi's death came at a cost
they did not now it's not exclusive
illicitly clear if thrawn ever acquired
that Hilt but price did present it to
him as a kind of Trophy and since thrawn
ends up on the planet lothal in the
final episodes of the series it's safe
to assume that the saber is now in his
possession and somewhere aboard the
Chimera since Ahsoka episode 7 ends with
Ezra excited to go home and the pergol
are all gone I think we're gonna see
these former Rebels sneaking aboard the
Chimera again Ezra loves to disguise
himself in stormtrooper armor and they
just killed a bunch of night Troopers
with mismatching armor perfectly ready
for them to slip on as a disguise but
the question is what is gonna happen
when Ezra gets on that ship what do the
night sister witches have in store for
him and them another very important
episode in Rebels was the season 3
episode visions and voices in which Ezra
joins Maul on the planet dathomir to
take part in a night sister ritual
drinking a special fluid and Awakening
the ghosts of past night sisters these
ghosts possess Sabine and Kanan and it
is while Sabine is under night sister
possession that she first picks up the
darksaber I have theorized in the past
that Sabine never would have picked up
the darksaber otherwise and the Very
concept of the darksaber re-entering
Star Wars lore was actually part of a
night sister curse if the great witches
have some Army of the Dead Resurrection
in the works and some green magic with
the K Ezra and Sabine could come full
circle with that moment from visions and
voices Sabine could finally figure out
why she's always struggled with
lightsabers and why she has some weird
Force sensitivity despite not clearly
being cut out to be a Jedi why she hears
these voices why she stinks to these
witches and why these witches did not
see her coming it could be because of
that night sister curse in visions of
voices that never left sabine's body so
Ezra now in the Chimera could find
himself back in those reconstructed
ruins of the lothal Jedi Temple there'd
be no reason for thrawn to dismantle
them and that could take him back to the
shallow end of the world Between Worlds
that Palpatine tried to use against him
in that Rebels finale with his parents
which would be interesting because it
would open up Ezra to other past mentors
who would also be able to connect to the
world Between Worlds like the ghosts of
maul and the Ghost of Kane and Jairus
and before we dismiss the live action
Kane and Jairus Cameo coming in this
finale just think about it folks on
Hera's dashboard all season long of
Ahsoka has been a photo of Kanan that
I'm pretty sure is the publicity photo
of Freddie Prinze Jr pretty Prince Jr of
course voiced the character if they can
get Hayden Christensen to return in a
ghostly form in the world Between Worlds
yeah they can get Freddy Dave filoni
never answered a number of mysteries
about Kanan in the rebels series from
the Doom wolf with whom Kanan shares his
birth name of Caleb doom and whatever
Kanan Caleb's history is on lothal based
on those cave markings that seem to
indicate that Caleb was part of a
prophecy to be brought to this planet by
Yoda and Mace Windu and kiari Mundi and
felloni brienin Jason sindula to the
series giving Jason kanan's pauldron
with that Doom simple hinting at Jason's
Force sensitivity to the world Between
Worlds doesn't it just kind of make
sense if we would see a force ghost of
Kanan Jairus in the last existing pieces
of the lothal Jedi Temple that he and
Esther visited multiple times one of the
times with Ahsoka and this also was the
location where Ezra acquired original
kyber crystal from a vision with Yoda
back in early seasons of rebels I just
think the reason Ezra doesn't want his
old lightsaber now is that he knows deep
down on some level that there is another
saber calling to him from the depths of
that ship and there is one more Rebels
reunion in the works to sanctify that
hand off but let me know in the comments
Below in my reaching is Dave filoni just
above bringing back Freddie Prince Jr to
play a live action ghostly form of Kane
and Jairus comment down below with your
thoughts please support this channel by
grabbing and Ahsoka inspired fulcrum
shirt available at nerdrive.shop also a
little announcement on Sunday Tommy and
I are gonna have a video on this channel
breaking down our final bets for the
Ahsoka finale please subscribe to all
three channels on the new rockstars
Network you can follow me on all social
platforms at EA boss follow me rockstars
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time bye
[Music]